dass der alte und der neue bürgermeister
gemeinsam ihren markt spaziergang
absolvieren ist in orange nichts
besonderes schließlich sind sie vater
und sohn jan born parat erst vor kurzem
den staffelstab übernommen weil sein
vater wegen unerlaubter einflussnahme
und hehlerei verurteilt wurde beide sind
beliebt und rechtsextrem
wie gehen wir mit den menschen auf
tuchfühlung hier spüren wir den puls
nicht
nur beim fischkauf sind natürlich die
nahen präsidentschaftswahlen ein thema
was den derzeitigen amtsinhaber makro
betrifft nimmt der bürgermeister kein
blatt vor den mund
stell dir vor wenn er noch mal gewählt
wird das wäre eine katastrophe
widerspruch bekommt er eher nicht die
meisten sind mit der
ausländerfeindlichen law & order politik
der beiden stadtoberen zufrieden
sie haben sich um die straßenbeleuchtung
um die parkplätze gekümmert und alle
haben gesagt das sind ja gar keine nazis
alles ist wie immer besser
ich bin nicht wirklich für die
immigration dann muss man sich ja auch
schützen
orange ist eine hübsche kleine stadt in
der provence mit einem beeindruckenden
amphitheater rund 30.000 einwohner und
seit 26 jahren mit einer rechtsextremen
stadtregierung
wir treffen jan born paar dem neuen
bürgermeister im rathaus er hofft dass
wie orange bald ganz frankreich von
rechtsaußen regiert wird und zwar von
einem newcomer am rechten rand eric
singer
verteidigte unsere nation jungen frauen
haben angst vor einer bestimmten
bevölkerungsgruppe die ihnen hinterher
pfeift sie als [ __ ] beschimpft sie
manchmal sogar schlägt oder vergewaltigt
es sind solche behauptungen mit denen er
ich sehe nur seine anhänger mobilisiert
frankreich drohe der untergang
angestoßen durch muslimische
einwanderung
ich bin der einzige kandidat der
realität ich glaube wir müssen brutal
sein weil frankreich sich retten will es
will nicht sterben
bei seinen auftritten ging es auch schon
mal handfest zu
menschenrechtsaktivisten wurden von
anhängern verprügelt journalisten an der
arbeit gehindert
auch simon selbst scheut sich nicht
seinen kritikern zu zeigen was er von
ihnen hält vor kurzem wurde er zum
dritten mal wegen volksverhetzung
verurteilt seine kruden thesen hat sie
nur der sohn jüdischer eltern schon als
journalist und buchautor in die welt
gesetzt und bei einem rechten
fernsehsender nikola b war lange sein
chef bei der zeitung le figaro sie muss
verbalattacken erstaunen ihn nicht
damals hatte er noch nicht diese
wortwahl diese art und weise in der er
jetzt seine ideen vor bringt dieses zu
weit gehen aber er hatte schon dieselben
überzeugungen
die wahlkampagne organisieren vor allem
mit zwanziger die sich für eric sie nur
begeistern sie nennen sich generation z
z wie sie nur einer von ihnen ist edith
verkehr mobilisiert die anhänger in den
hochschulen wir treffen ihn in einem gut
situierten viertel von paris wo er wohnt
sie nur das ist für ihn den
bwl-studenten der mann der zukunft
er ist brillant er argumentiert gut er
hat eine persönlichkeit die mitreißt und
er ist sehr sympathisch
lange zeit war sie die galionsfigur der
extremen rechten marien lücken 2017
schaffte sie es in die stichwahl gegen
emanuel makro sie hatte ihrer partei
einen weicheren kurs verordnet ihr
hauptthema aber bleibt dasselbe die
emigration und der islamismus jetzt
macht er ein neuer konkurrent die
wählerschaft streitig marine le pen
wehrt sich und spricht sie nur die
kompetenz ab
einige personen übertreiben maßlos wenn
es um einwanderungspolitik geht weil sie
auf diesem gebiet nicht glaubwürdig sind
und weil sie nicht glaubwürdig sind
werden sie nass
le pen sie laut umfragen wollen etwa 30
prozent der franzosen rechtsextrem
wählen so viele wie noch nie das liege
auch an einer allgemeinen
politikverdrossenheit sagt die
soziologin no name
es gibt eine demokratie müdigkeit mein
misstrauen gegenüber der politischen
klasse
die repräsentative demokratie ist in der
krise das macht den wahlausgang sehr
ungewiss
wir fahren in die berge wo die menschen
leben auf diesem ohr und lippen mit dem
finger zeigen die cité nadal ein
plattenbau dschungel ohne seele boa
migrationsanteil hoher arbeitslosigkeit
fiel kleinkriminalität und immer wieder
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
jugendlichen und polizisten ja es gibt
probleme sagen sie hier ganz offen aber
nicht alle vorurteile mit denen die
politiker spiel seien richtig bei einem
verein der kinder betreut und fördert
treffen wir die studentin sabrina sie
ist im viertel geboren
es gibt leute die denken schlecht von
denen die hier leben ich empfinde das
nicht so wir sind eine große familie
wir kennen uns alle sind zusammen groß
geworden in dieselbe schule gegangen und
jetzt helfen wir den jungen ihren weg zu
gehen
quasi nebenan trainiert der sie ziehen
am boxsack er ist lehrer hier im viertel
und findet dass die politiker ein sehr
einseitiges bild der bohne zeichnen
in meiner klasse gibt es keine
religiösen befindlichkeiten alle lachen
zusammen alle leben miteinander es ist
die politik die versucht den menschen
angst zu machen
trotz des erstarkens der rechtsextremen
die politikverdrossenheit ist hier so
groß dass viele gar nicht wählen gehen
in orange dagegen wird die beteiligung
an den präsidentschaftswahlen im april
wohl hoch sein mit wahrscheinlich vielen
stimmen für rechtsaußen
[Musik]